you're an athlete as a young person you
didn't have designs on getting into
acting in theater you were literally
dragged off the basketball court to be
in a musical theater is it that's what I
forgot we up in this small town and that
meant we had a like a hundred and fifty
people in our graduating class and and
they needed guys and she was doing the
director was doing South Pacific which
needs a lot of sailors and so I was
coming out of a basketball practice I'd
been in choir so she knew I could carry
a tune and I'm walking by and we had
just lost our like 10th game in a row so
all we did was run you know and I'm dead
and she sees me coming so the
auditoriums right there and she goes get
in here I'm like oh my god I go in she
says get up there and do a dance so
they're gonna sing nothing like a dame
or something and so I got up there and
it was the beginning I was a sophomore
in high school and I got up in front of
audition people and danced and I did I
did this
[Applause]
thank you a career was good still works
did you have that moment of feeling like
yeah I've got the bug I want to do this
no I thought I'm I'm being stupid right
now I could make a living at this
yeah I've never known that what I could
do this but it it people laughed and
then she put me in the play and and I
did that I had two lines but I did the
dance and 700 people in an auditorium
went nuts and I'm going hmm right might
be something there might be something
there it'd be great if we then showed a
montage of your career and it was you in
movies and film and theater doing that
all you did over and over again yeah do
that at the store I'm gonna go in on
Thursday and just do it in the middle
over near the Cheetos yeah you're doing
it there yeah yeah the police leave you
alone all right
you